by now many people will be aware that
the council have deliberated the draft
annual plan our budget as mirin
counselors we worked with council staff
to quickly revise our budget during the
lockdown to keep rate increases as low
as possible from a proposed 4% down to
one point five percent rate increases
will vary depending on the property but
generally speaking an average property
will see an increase of approximately
forty-five dollars a year or $11 25 per
quarter to get to 1.5 percent we've
taken a long hard look at our finances
and adjusted our plans projections and
assumptions for the coming years we've
heard from residents what they wanted
and that was to keep their increases as
low as possible this year while
positioning the council to help
Waimakariri recover and this is what
we've done the changes to the budget has
saved 2.9 million dollars in spending
and also 2.2 million in plan rates
funding during the lockdown the council
lost 2.25 million an income which shows
that the significant savings have been
made hitting our rates down to this
point the council will believe will help
in the short term while also minimizing
the locally felt in longer lasting
effects of covert 19 Thanks to everyone
who made a submission and shared their
view we really appreciated that hope
that you all enjoy the upcoming Queen's
birthday weekend
you